okay so let's begin first of all I want
to say congratulations you all survived
the exam well you don't have your grades
back but you you completed it so yeah I
just want to say so we're gonna have the
grades back as soon as we can the CAS
are all busy grading and we're actually
going to cancel office hours today so we
can focus on getting those grades back
to you quickly after this the course
definitely goes downhill so you guys can
kind of like take a break so after the
exam there's pretty much just two things
left so there's the project so the final
presentation the poster session for the
project is going to be I believe that
Tuesday after vacation it's like a big
auditorium hall those give me a lot of
people from industry and academia it's
really exciting to have like you know so
many smart people are showing off their
hard work and then you have the last
piece set which is logic yeah
Oh Monday okay yeah so months of right
after you back from vacation is that
poster session and then on Thursday is
the last piece that is due logic so
logic is so this is not like my official
opinion but I think logic when I took
the class was easier than the others it
doesn't take as much time so you guys
are definitely past the hardest point is
class yeah I think I think that's the
general opinion yeah but that being said
I wouldn't wait until the last minute so
start really yeah ok so then yeah so
Piazza and office hours will be your
best friend yeah okay so but today
though we're talking about this fun
advanced ish topic which is deep
learning
I say ish because I think a lot of you
are probably working on deep learning or
I've heard of it already a lot of you
have it in your projects and today we're
just kind of do very very high-level
broad pass
different subjects within deep learning
hopefully get you excited give you kind
of like a shallow understanding of a lot
of different topics so that if you want
to take follow-up classes like to 24 N
or 229 even then you'll be armed with
some kind of background knowledge
okay so first we're going to talk about
the history so deep learning you've
probably heard of it it's really big
especially in the last 5-10 years but
it's actually been around for a long
time so even back to the 40's there's
this era where people are trying to
build more computational neuroscience
models they noticed that they knew back
then that you know there's neurons in
the brain and they're arranged in these
networks and I know that elegance arises
from these small parts and so they
really wanted to model that the first
people to really do this where McCulloch
and Pitt's so Pitts was actually
logician and it was they were concerned
with making these kind of like logical
circuits out of a network like topology
like what kind of logical expressions
can we implement with a network back
then this was this was all just a
mathematical model like there was no
back propagation there are no parameters
there was no inference it was just
trying to write about fruit I guess like
theorems and proofs about what kind of
problems these structures can solve and
then head came along about ten years
later and started moving things in the
direction of I guess like training these
networks he noticed that if two cells
are firing a lot together then they
should have some kind of connection that
is strong and this is a was inspired by
observation so there's actually no
formal math theory backing this it was a
lot of it was just very smart people
making conjecture and then it wasn't
until the 60s that so neural networks
was I guess you could say maybe in the
mainstream like a lot of people were
thinking about it and excited about it
until 1969 when McKenzie and pepper they
released this
very famous book called perceptrons
which was this like big fat book of
proofs and they were basically talking
about the they proved a bunch of
theorems that were about the limits of
very shallow neural networks so for
example early I think very very early in
this class we talked about the XOR
example where if you have two classes
and they're arranged in this
configuration then there's no there's no
linear classification boundary that you
can use to separate them and cross by
them correctly and so there we can ski
pepper in their brook perceptrons they
came up with a lot of these I guess you
could say like counter examples like
that a lot of theorems that really
proved that these thin neural networks
couldn't really do a lot and at the time
it was it was a little bit of a killing
blow to neural network research so
mainstream AI became much more logical
and neural networks were pushed very
much into I guess a minority group so
there's always people thinking about and
working on it but the mainstream a I
went definitely towards kind of the
symbolic logic based methods that
Percy's been talking about the last
couple of weeks but like I said there's
still these people in the background
working on it so for example in 1974
we're both C came up with this idea the
back propagation that we learned about
using the chain rule to automatically
update weights in order to improve
predictions and then later on so Hinton
and rumelhart Williams they kind of I
guess you could say they popularized
this so they they definitely I guess you
could say rediscovered war BOCES
findings and they really said oh hey
everybody you can use back propagation
and it's a mathematical fail well kind
of like well founded way of training
these like deep neural networks and then
in the 80s so today we're going to talk
about two types of neural networks
convolution
networks and recurrent neural networks
and the convolutional networks traced
back to the 80s so there's this neo
cognate Ron that was invented by a
Japanese Fukushima and it kind of laid
out the architecture for a CNN but there
was no way of training it and in the
actual paper they used hand-tuned
weights they were like oh hey there's
this architecture you can use and
basically we just like buy travel and
Eric came up with these numbers to plug
in it and look at how it works now it
just seems like insane but back then
that was this you know there were no
ways of training these things until
McCune came about ten years later and so
he applied those ideas of
backpropagation to CNN's and laocoön
actually came out with a so there's the
laocoön net which was a very famous
check reading system and it was one of
the first like industrial large-scale
applications of deep learning so
whenever you write a check in and have
your bank read it almost all the time
there's a machine learning model that
reads that check for you and those check
reading systems are some of the oldest
machine learning models that have been
like use at scale and then later so
we're kernel networks came in the 90s so
Elliman kind of proposed it and then
there's this problem with training it
that we'll talk about later called
expect exploding or vanish ingredients
and then grater and zoom breeder
about ten years later came out with I
guess you could say maybe a it solved to
some extent those issues with a long
short-term memory Network lsdm and we'll
talk about that later and then but I
guess you could still say that no
networks were kind of in the minority so
in the 80s you used a lot of rule-based
AI in the 90s people were all about
support vector machines and inventing
new kernels if you remember support
vector machine is basically just like
it's it's a linear classifier with the
hinge loss and a kernel is a way of
projecting
data into it kind of like a nonlinear
subspace but it was in the 2000s people
finally started making progress and so
Hinton had this cool idea of hey we can
train these deep let works one layer at
a time so we'll pre train one layer and
then we'll pre train a second layer and
stack that on third layer stack that on
and you can build up these sexist
representations and then deep learning
kind of became a thing so this looks
like maybe three four years ago really
started taking off and ever since then
it's really been in the mainstream and
you can kind of proof evidence towards
its mainstream this you can look at all
of these applications so speech
recognition for about almost a decade
this performance in speech recognition
severe recognizers were using hidden
Markov model based like that was in that
was the heart of these algorithms and
for ten years performance just stagnated
and then all of a sudden their own that
was him around
drop that formats and what's most
surprising is that all of the big comes
so IBM Google Microsoft they all
switched over from these classical
speech recognizers into fully end-to-end
neural network based recognizers very
quickly in a matter of years and when
these these large companies are
operating at scale and they've you know
dozens maybe hundreds of people have
tuned these systems very intricately and
for them to so quickly and so radically
shift the core technology behind this
product really speaks to its power
same thing with object recognition so
there's this image net competition which
goes on every year that says basically
like how well can you say what's in a
picture and the first and so for years
people use these handcrafted features
and all of a sudden Alix net was
proposed and it almost got half the
error of the next-best submission for
this competition and then ever since
then people have been using neural
networks and now if you want to do
computer vision
you kind of have to use these CNN's it's
just a default if you walk into a
conference every single poster is gonna
have a CNN in it
same thing with go so google deepmind
had I had a CNN based algorithm they
trained with reinforcement learning and
it beat the world champion in this very
difficult game and then in 2017 it did
even better didn't even need a like real
data it just did self play and machine
translation so Google Translate for
almost a decade had been working on
building a very very advanced and very
well performing classical machine
translation system and then all of a
sudden the first machine translation
system was proposed in like 2014-2015
and then about a year later they threw
away ten you know almost a decade of of
work on this system and transferred
entirely to a completely new algorithm
which again speaks to its power so but
what is I guess deep learning like what
you know why is this thing so powerful
why is it so good and I think so broadly
speaking it's a way of learning of
taking data you can slurp up any kind of
data you want like a sequence a picture
even vectors or even like a game like go
and you can turn it into a vector and
this vector is gonna be a dense
representation of whatever information
is captured by that data and this is
very powerful because these vectors are
compositional and you can use these
components these modules of your deep
learning system kind of like Lego blocks
you can you know concatenate vectors and
add them together and use this to modify
you and just the compositionality makes
it very flexible ok so today we're going
to talk about feed for electronics
convolutional metrics which work on
images or I guess just anything with
repeated complex structural information
in it we're currently networks which
operate
for sequences and then if we have time
we'll get to some unsupervised learning
topics
okay so first for feed-forward networks
so in the very beginning this class we
talked about linear predictors linear
predictor if you remember is basically
you define like a vector W that's your
weights and then you hit it with some
input and you dot them together and that
just gives your output and neural
networks we define very similarly so you
can think of each of these hidden units
as the result of a linear predictor in a
way so working backwards you so you have
that you define a vector W and you hit
it with some activation function with
some activation like inputs some hidden
inputs and you dot that with your hidden
and you get your output and then you
arrive with either your hidden by
defining a vector and hitting it with
inputs so you use your inputs to compute
hidden numbers and then you use your
hidden numbers to compete your final
output so in a way you're kind of like I
guess stacking linear predictors like
each each number so H 1 H 2 and F of
theta are all the product I guess you
could say they're all the result of like
a little mini linear predictor they're
all kind of like roped together
so just to visualize this if we want to
go deeper you just rinse and repeat
so this is you could say this is a one
layer neural network it's what we were
talking about before with linear
predictor you just you have your vector
weights and you apply it to your inputs
for a two-layer you apply instead of a
vector to your inputs you apply a matrix
here inputs which gives you a new vector
and then you dot this intermediate
vector this hidden vector with another
set of weights and that gives you your
final output and then you
can just rinse the repeat so you pass
through a vector you pass through a
matrix to get a new vector you pass that
through another matrix to get a new
vector and then you finally at the very
end
dot it with a vector to get a single
number so just a word about depth that's
one of the reasons why these things are
really powerful so there's a lot of
interpretations for why depth is helpful
and why kind of like stacking these
matrices works well one way to think
about it is that it learns
representations of the input which are
hierarchical so H is going to be some
kind of representation of X H prime is
going to be a slightly higher level
representation of X so for example in a
lot of image processing systems H maybe
represents H could represent like the
edges in a picture H prime would
represent like corners H double prime
could represent like small like fingers
or something H triple prime would be the
whole hand so it's successfully I guess
you could say like just higher level
representations of what's in the data
you're giving it another way to think
about it is each layer is kind of like a
step in processing and you could think
of it maybe like a for loop where it
sits like the more the more the more
iterations you have the more steps you
have the more depth you have the more
processing you're able to perform on the
input and then last the deeper the
network is the more kinds of functions
it can represent and so the yeah so
there's flexibility in that as well but
in general there isn't really a good
formal understanding of why depth is
helpful and I think a lot of deep
learning is there's definitely a gap
between the etherion
practice so yeah so this I guess just
goes to show why depth is helpful so if
you input pixels maybe your first layer
is giving you edge detection and your
second layer is giving you little eyes
or noses or ears and then your third
layer and above is giving you whole
objects yeah so just to summarize so we
have these deep neural networks and they
learn hierarchical representation of the
data especially I guess you could say
it's like gaining altitude in its
perspective you can train them the same
way that we learned you can train them
the same way that we learned how to
train our linear classifiers just with
gradient descent so you have your loss
function you take the derivative with
respect to your loss and then you
propagate the gradients to step in a
direction that you think would be
helpful and this optimization problem is
difficult so it it's nonlinear and non
convex but in general if we found that
if you throw like a lot of data at it a
lot of compute at it and somehow you
managed ok so it seems like the slides
are a little out of order but basically
just to review how you train these
things in general it's the same as a
linear predictor you define a loss
function so for example this is squared
loss where you'd say I'm going to take
the difference between my true output
and my predicted output and square that
and then the idea is to minimize this
and the way you do that is you sample
data points from your training data and
you take the derivative of your
parameters with respect to this with
respect to your loss function and then
you move in the opposite direction of
that gradient which would hopefully move
you down on the error surface so
the problem is a non convex optimization
problem so for example linear classifier
because it's linear we'll have a cut
it'll just look like a bowl whereas
these things you have these nonlinear
activation functions and you end up with
a very messy looking error surface and
before the 2000s that was the big that
was the number one thing that was
holding back neural networks is that
they were difficult to get working hard
to train and so basically the thing
that's changed is one way faster
computers we have GPUs which can
paralyze operations especially those big
matrix multiplications and then there's
a lot more data that's not entirely true
so there's also a lot of other tricks
that we found out recently so for
example if you have lots of hidden units
then that can be helpful because it
gives more it gives more flexibility you
could say in the optimization like if
you have if you over-provision if your
model has two more capacity than it
needs then you can be more flexible with
the kind of functions that you can learn
so we have better optimizers so whereas
SGD will make it'll take it'll step in
the same direction by the same amount
every time we have these newer
optimizers like auto granite atom that
decide how far to move in a direction
once you've decided the direction we
have drop out which is where you noise
the outputs of each hidden unit and that
makes the model more robust to its own
errors and it guards against overfitting
there's better initialization strategies
so there's things like save your
initialization and there's things like
pre training the model on a related data
set before moving on to the data you
actually care about and then there's
tricks like back to norm which is where
you ensure that the inputs to your
neural network units have are normally
distributed
they have mean 0 standard deviation 1
and what that does is allows you to
basically take bigger steps sizes yeah
and the takeaway here is that but in
general the optimization problem and the
model architecture you define are very
tightly coupled and it's kind of a black
magic to get that right balance that you
need and we're still not very good at it
okay so we're going to talk about
convolutional neural networks now and so
these operate over images the motivation
is that okay so we have a picture here
right and we want to do some kind of
machine learning processing on it we
have all the tools that we need to do
that you could say okay each picture
each pixel is an element in a big long
vector and then I'm just gonna throw
that out of matrix but the thing is is
that that doesn't really take advantage
of the fact that there's spatial
structure in this picture so this pixel
is gonna be more similar to this pixel
than this pixel down here but if you
pass this entire thing through a matrix
then every pixel is gonna be treated
uniquely differently and so we want to
leverage that spatial structure and the
idea to the core idea is with
convolutions so convolutions you have
this thing called a filter which is some
collection parameters and what you do is
you run your filter over the input in
order to produce each output element so
for example this filter when applied to
this upper left corner produces this
upper left corner of the output and an
application of a filter works kind of
like a dot product where you multiply
you multiply all the numbers and then
you add up them all up and so how you
produce these outputs as you take your
filter and you basically just slide it
around in the input in order to get your
output at the next layer
so yeah so this this example zone one
concrete so here so whereas this was a
two dimensional convolution because we
had a two dimensional filter and we were
sliding around in both dimensions this
is one dimensional we have a one
dimensional filter and we slide it
horizontally across so for example at
the very left we apply it so 1 times 0
is 0 0 times 1 is 1 and negative 1 times
2 is negative 2 so negative 2 goes in
the output and then we do the similar
thing here so we would dot product this
filter with these three numbers in order
to arrive at to one of the advantages of
this is that whereas a so if you had so
if you had let's say you had like 4
inputs you so this is your hidden layer
so Y h1 h2 h3 and h4 and then you had 4
inputs x1 x2 x3 and x4 if you did a
regular fully connected matrix layer
then every one of these is going to be
connected to every one of these and your
parameters
you're gonna you're going to end up with
a 4 by 4 matrix 1 1 W 1 2 W 1 3 w 1 4
and W this is what your matrix is going
to look like if this is your W because
you need that new you need a weight for
every one of those connections whereas
if you're doing convolutions it's much
more efficient because there's this idea
of local connectivity so you have your 1
H 2 H 3 H 4 X 1 X 2
each hidden layer is only connected to
what's called its receptive field which
is the inputs that the filter would be
applied to and in this case we would
only have three weights because we just
have this sliding window and you apply
it at each step so a gives you local
connectivity B it's much more efficient
in terms of parameters you you're
sharing the same parameters at different
places in the input and it gives you
this cool intuition of sliding around in
the input so it's like I have my filter
of three things and it gives you this
good intuition of if if a let's say this
is let's say this is negative one this
is a hundred this is 1 and this is 3
then what this you could you can
interpret this as my filter really likes
whatever pattern is going on in these
three inputs and it doesn't like so much
all the other patterns that it's picking
up on and so yeah you have this nice
interpretation for the filters in
general what this looks like is so in
practice instead of one dimensional two
dimensional they're very high
dimensional volumes and so your filter
is going to be a cube in the input space
and you're sliding it around and
applying it at every place it can fit in
this input and then the reason why the
output is also a volume is because you
have multiple filters so over here for
example this blue filter is when you
slide it around in the input it's going
to give you this like plane of outputs
but then you have a second filter this
green filter that you can also slider on
the input
and that's going to give you a second
dimension to your hidden states so Andre
Karthi has this nice demo where
basically we have so we have a
three-dimensional input and we have two
filters which are like you can think of
as little cubes and it's sliding these
cubes around the input and every
application gives you one output in this
like three dimensional output volume so
this is the same picture as before where
you sliding around cubes in order to
fill in you could say like layers of the
out put solar on cubes to fill in these
layers of the output another thing
people do is max pooling so remember
that interpretation of a filter as a as
like a pattern detector what this is
saying is you take a region in your
input so you you run your filters of the
input get your like preliminary output
and then you look at regions in the
output and take the maximum activation
and carry that on two successive layers
and the intuition there is that instead
of that you're looking you're searching
for a pattern in a region of the input
and it's also helpful because remember
at the end of the day we want to do
classification or regression or
something we want to get this thing down
to like a very small number of numbers
and if we have this huge high
dimensional volume then anyway we can
reduce its size is good so this is an
example of how these things work is is
it's they're pretty straightforward
basically so you you just have your
convolutional layers you stack them all
up everyone somebody have some pooling
and you go down and down in
dimensionality until you eventually get
down to a like a distribution over
possible labels and this ties
saying before about that Lego block
analogy because this this entire network
is built up of one two three four
different Lego blocks in a way and it's
basically just stacking them on top of
each other and composing them up in
order to get a image classifier so I'm
going to talk about three case studies
of CNN architectures so the first one is
Alex net so this was that one that did
really well in the image net competition
and really brought CNN's to the
mainstream for computer vision basically
it was just a really big neural network
one trick they did was they use Braille
use instead of so the sigmoid that we've
learned about I think we've the sigmoid
that we've learned about this is an
activation function and it's going to
look something like this
and what they did was instead they used
the review which looks a little more
like that and in practice it turns out
to be a little easier to train and use
the next one is Vida Gina which did them
imagenet a couple years later basically
it's very similar it's just a CNN I
think the thing to note about this one
is that it's very uniform so it was 16
layers and there's nothing fancy in it
it was just a bunch of these Lego blocks
stacked up the entire network is pretty
much like you just by looking at this
picture you could probably reimplemented
out it is it started this trend of
deeper of kind of like tall and skinny
networks so you'll notice that there's a
lot of layers but each layer is very
thin and residual networks or rez Nets
kind of takes that to the nth degree so
the idea with ResNet is
so most of the time you take your input
you pass it through a matrix state an
output if you add in your input again
then that is very helpful because it
makes it easy for the model to learn the
identity function and so you can give
the model the capacity for like a
hundred layers but if you add in these
residual connections which is what you
call it when you basically just like
added and I'd add an X then it allows
the model to skip a layer if it decides
that that's what's best for itself you
just set W to zero that's what you do so
it also helps with training back
propagation if you take the derivative
of the loss with respect to your input
that derivative is just gonna be one for
this part of the sum and so it gives in
a way you could think of it as its it
gives the it gives the error signal kind
of like a highway through the network
and it allows the gradients to propagate
much deeper into these large networks
and so ResNet got three point six
percent error on image net if you
remember the alux net way it blew
everyone all the water and i got like
fifteen percent i think this is much
better than human performance and it
will come up later when we talk about
this idea of like residual connections
we're current mental networks so just to
summarize convolutional neural networks
are often applied in image
classification the key idea is that
there is you have these filters which
you are sliding around the input and
that lets you one have it does kind of
this like I give local connectivity so
as a space in the app in the output only
depends on a small patch at the input
instead of the entire input and then
second
it's the perimeters are shared depth has
turned out to really matter for these
networks and I think to this day it's
like people it's like every day there's
just a deeper network that's coming out
and people haven't really found a bound
to death I guess yeah design intuition
that said how many layers what the
layers should be and so forth yeah so
the question was how to design these
things since this it seems so arbitrary
and yeah it is it is really arbitrary I
think I think so there's a few different
ways so first you start with something
okay so first you would start with
something that sounds reasonable and
then you would do some kind of like a
grid search or you would do now there is
a literature on medal earning which is
where like you have a model decide what
your model looks like or but in most
cases you just kind of like and tune it
you're like oh if I add a layer does it
go up or down second you look at the
literature and say okay someone else
solved a similar problem to me and they
used network XYZ and so I'm gonna start
with that and then start fiddling from
there and then third is to literally
take that network that's been pre
trained on a task and then apply it to
yours we'll talk about it later but
pre-training networks and applying that
to your task has shown to be very
helpful okay so now we're going to talk
about recurrent neural networks the idea
here is that you're modeling sequences
of input this could be things like text
or sentences it could also be things
like time series data or financial data
and a recurrent Lamarque is something
where the input
feeds its past inputs into itself so it
has time dependencies so for example we
have this very simple recurrent neural
network here it is a function with one
matrix and it takes as arguments a past
hidden state and a current input and
then it predicts the next hidden state
so this this is what it looks like if
you were to write it in code or
something this is what the actual
network looks like so there's an input
and you feed that into your function as
well as your current state and it just
kind of loops on itself and most of the
time people talk about this third
perspective which is taking kind of this
network and I and kind of like
unraveling it across time I guess you
can say unfolding it across time where
every time step you have an input and
you have a state and then you have your
function which carries you to your next
state yeah excuse me colleges defer from
having your original oh I see so the
question was what's the difference
between this and the setting before when
we had when we were like the cost of
gradient descent where we were updating
our weights sequentially yeah so that is
that is an interesting question so the
in the difference is that before for SGD
that was for it was sequential in the
training whereas this is sequential in
the inference so each so you do you feed
in 10 inputs let's say 10 times such
those are inputs and then after all that
time then you back propagate
once for all those time steps so to make
that more clear
so for SGD it's like you have x1 y1 x2
y2 and you use this to update W right so
you update W and then you update W and
yeah that's that's an interesting
observation that there's this kind of
like time dependency on but there's no
time within the data itself for for the
recurrent setting it's it's more like
this it's like if I'm which marker is
better so it's more like this it's more
like you have X 1 1 X 1 2 X 1 3 and Y
and then X 2 1 X 2 2 and X 2 3 and Y and
then you use this to update W and in
this setting when we talk about time or
temporal and like when we talk about a
sequence we're talking about a sequence
here in the data not necessarily in the
learning yeah ok so to me this is a more
concrete example we're going to talk
about a neural network language model so
this is a model that is in charge of
sucking in a sentence and predicting
what is the most likely word that would
come next in the sentence so we're so
each input we call X and our hidden
States we call H's and the way this
works is we have some function that
takes X 1 and it codes it in to our
hidden state and then we have a second
function that takes the hidden state and
decodes it into the next input
we continue by taking both the next both
x2 our next have input and h1 our
previous hidden state and then we use
that to and create a new hidden encoding
and then we take that new hidden
encoding and decoding to our next input
and we just rinse and repeat each time
we take the current input and the
previous hidden state to first create an
encoding and then second predict our
next input
you
so there's those two steps
the cool thing about this to note is
that this now were building up vectors
these H ice and that's exactly what
we're looking for it's a vector that in
some way captures the meaning or a
summary of all the X all the inputs that
we've fed up until that time step so now
we have a vector which compresses all
those inputs into one vector so to make
this very concrete one way you could
build this thing is by basically each of
these arrows you stick a matrix in there
so our encode function would take the
input the XT and multiply it by a matrix
in order to get a vector and then it
would take the previous hidden state HT
minus one and multiply that by different
matrix to get a new vector then you add
those vectors and that gives you a
vector which is your new hidden state
and your decode is the same thing you
take your hidden state pass it through a
matrix to get a vector and then send
that through a softmax to turn the
vector of logits into a distribution of
probabilities
in general though there's this problem
with kernel networks so if there is a
short dependency between the input and
the output if an output depends on a
recent input then the path through this
network is very short right so it's easy
for the gradients to reach where it
needs to reach in order to train the
network properly but if there was a very
long dependency then the gradients have
a had they have difficulty getting all
the way through you so if you remember
we talked about gradient descent as a
credit assignment problem where the
gradient is in some ways like saying how
much okay so if I change the input if I
change this input by a small if I
perturb by a small amount how much would
the output change that's in what sense
that what the gradient is saying but if
the input and output are super far away
from each other then it's very difficult
to compute how small perturbations the
input would affect your output and the
reason for that we won't get into it so
much but basically if you want to
compute the gradient then what you have
to do is you have to trace the entire
path of that dependency and you look at
all the partial derivatives along that
path and you multiply them all up and so
the problem is is that if the path is
very long then you're multiplying a lot
of numbers and so if your numbers are
less than one then the then the product
the over product is gonna get really
small really fast right and if the
numbers are bigger than one then that
product is going to blow up really
quickly
and so that is a problem because it
means your gradients are going to be
tiny and you know learning signal or
they're going to be way too big and
you're going to just like shoot into
some crazy direction that in practice
will like blow up your experiments and
nothing will work so it's problem so for
the
good thing is that for the exploding
braiding problem that's not so bad
there's a quick fix what people do is
what they do is what's called clipping
gradients so you'll specify some norm
you'll be like any gradient with a norm
bigger than two I'm going to clamp off
at two so if your greens explode and
they go to ten million you're gonna say
okay that's bigger than two so it was it
wasn't ten million it was actually two
but for the finishing grading problem
there's this cool idea the long
short-term memory cell which is similar
to a recurrent law at work but it has
two hidden states and so this is kind of
a wall of equations but I think the
important thing to note is that you're
doing this this is basically like your
input in a way and this is kind of like
your previous hidden state and so what's
going on here is you're doing an
additive combination you're taking your
input and you're adding in your previous
hidden state very similarly to those
residual connections in the resin ette
and so this because you're adding in
your previous state it's kind of like
adding in your proofs input I guess you
could say and it allow it gives the
gradients kind of like a highway to very
easily go back in time there's another
perspective on this so this picture that
in the notation is different but I think
the thing to note here is that this so
those those are are you could say our
hidden states in this network or I guess
so in an LTM cell you could I guess you
could say that there's two hidden states
that's what people say so you have one
hidden state which is your HT and that's
the state that you exposed to the world
and if you said my else team is gonna
have the same API as my RNN then this
would be like the equivalent of that
hidden state that we had for the Arnett
but then you also have this in
ternal hidden state the sea state that
you never exposed to the world and so in
this picture the sorry the notation is a
little confusing but the Oh a Mis
picture corresponds to the H in the
previous perfect picture so this is the
hidden state that you're exposing to the
world and then the S corresponds to C so
this is your internal hidden state and
the thing to note about this picture is
that s is just zipping around on what's
called the constant air cárcel and it's
always internal and it's zipping around
this thing in a loop and so what it ends
up doing in practice is it ends up work
like that it's a vector and it contains
very long term information that's useful
for the network over many many time
steps
so if you if you poke around individual
dimensions of that state then you and
then you can find these long-term things
being learned so for example Andre
Karthi has a great blog post you find
networks that you find units that track
the length of the sentence you find
units that track syntactic cues like
quotes or brackets but in general you
find a lot of things that are just not
easily interpretable so one last cool I
guess idea that people have used with
these were criminal networks is sequence
of sequence models like machine
translation which is where you have two
sequences you have an input sequence in
an output sequence and you want to suck
in your input sequence and then spit out
your output sequence and you do this
with what's called a encoder decoder
paradigm you encode your sequence by
giving it to your RNN and that gives you
a 1 vector which is encoding or a
compression of that input and then you
decode your sequence by spitting out
your outputs just like we were talking
about before with the language model
and more recently there's these
attention based models which are very
helpful in the case where there's long
sequences so if you look back here X 1 X
1 X 2 X 3 are all getting compressed
into a single vector well if you have a
really long paragraph maybe it's hard to
shove that into your you know 200
dimensional vector it's hard to capture
the depth of all that language with just
a bunch of numbers and so the idea
behind attention is to is to look back
so the way attention works is at a very
high level is so if you have your inputs
we have x1 x2 and x3 and we've run our
RNN over these inputs and so we have
three hidden state vectors h1 h2 and h3
and now we're decoding and so we have we
have our nand decoder that has some
hidden state we'll call it s1 what
happens is you compare your current hand
state with all of the states in your
encoder and you compute a number that
says how much do I like this state so
maybe maybe it like really really likes
this number and it's not too happy about
this number this vector and it doesn't
like this vector what it does is it is
it uses these scores to turn them into a
distribution a probability distribution
that again says how much how much do I
as s1 like each of these vectors and
then what you do is you compute a
weighted average of these hidden vectors
where the weights come from this
distribution and what this does is it
serves two purposes so first and there's
another way of kind of writing this down
on the slides but I think this serves
two purposes so first of all it gives
you some interpretation so every time
step you can see what parts of the input
is it focusing on what parts the inputs
have a lot of probability mass on them
and then second what it lets you do is
it lets you it kind of releases the
model from the pressure of having to put
the entire in
put sequins into a single vector now
what it can do is it can dynamically go
back and retrieve the information it
needs and then more recently there's
what's called transformer models which
are which do away entirely with the RNN
aspect it's just attention and with a
transformer you have your hidden states
and instead of instead of having some
kind of decoder hidden state that you're
comparing to the others what you're
doing is you just you select each hidden
state and you compare h1 to all the
other H's including itself to get a
number of how much h1 likes those other
H's and then you compute your weighted
average of all of these hidden states
and that becomes your next layer so I
would recommend taking 224 n if you're
interested in this topic transformers
are very cool and they've recently
become I guess you could say like the
new LS TM so from these attention
distributions you get cool interpretable
maps like in translations so this is an
attention distribution and it points at
words that are correspondent so like
economic corresponds to economic and and
you can see that in the distribution
they also do this in computer vision you
can highlight areas of a picture
yeah so just to summarize so we're
currently rx you can throw a sequence at
them and they'll give you a vector
there's this intuition that they are
processing input sequentially kind of
like a for loop but they have a problem
with training where the gradients either
blow up or they shrink very small so LS
TMS are one way of mitigating this
problem but they're not perfect they
still have to shove information into one
vector and so the way people get around
this is with attention based models
where you dynamically go back into your
input and retrieve the information you
need as you need it so now we're going
to talk about unsupervised learning so
like I said before neural networks we
got them to work well recently and a lot
of that is just because they need a lot
of data but if you're a smaller lab or
if you don't have enough money to
basically pay for a data set or even if
it's a hard problem that just there
isn't a lot of data forward there's a
lot of cases where there isn't enough
data to train these very very large
models with millions billions of
parameters but on the other hand there's
tons of unlabeled data laying around now
you can download the whole internet if
you want
and there's kind of this real
inspiration from us as human beings like
we are never given labelled data sets of
of what foods are edible and what foods
are not edible right you just kind of
you absorb experiences from the world
and you use that to inform your future
experiences and you're able to kind of
like reason about it and make decisions
so yeah so the first I guess thing that
we're gonna get into is Auto cutters so
the idea behind autoencoders is that if
you have some information and you try to
learn a compressed representation that
information that allows you to
reconstruct it then presumably you've
done something useful so in neural
network speak the way that works is you
give it some kind of effector and you
pass that through an encoder which gives
you a hidden vector and then you pass
that hidden vector through a decoder
which you use to reconstruct your input
and the implicit loss in most cases is
you want to take the difference
basically you want your reconstructed
input and the original input to be very
similar
so just to motivate this this isn't deep
learning but principal component
analysis is could be viewed as one of
these encoder decoders the idea behind
principal analysis is you want to come
up with a matrix U which can be used to
both encode and decode a vector so you
multiply X by u to give you a hidden
vector or a new representation of your
data but then if you transpose u and
multiply it by your hidden vector then
that should give you something as close
as possible to your original data
so but there's a problem so as we if we
have a hidden vector with a bunch of
units then it's not gonna learn anything
right it's just gonna learn how to copy
inputs into outputs and so a lot of
research on Auto encoding and this kind
of unsupervised learning is about how to
control the complexity and and make the
model robust enough to generate useful
representations instead of just copying
so the first pass at that can be using
lawnmower transformations so you would
do something like little logistic or the
sigmoid loss and that means that the
problem can't be solved any more by just
copying into the output and so you're
gonna have to actually learn something
useful
another way of doing it is by corrupting
the input so you have your input and you
noise it may be you drop out some
numbers from it maybe you perturb some
numbers of it maybe you add in maybe
draw from like a Gaussian and add that
to your input and then you pass that
through so yeah so you could drop so if
your vector is 1 2 3 4 you could drop
out 1 in 4 and just set them to 0 or you
could slightly perturb these numbers so
that they're close to their original but
different not the exact same and then
the idea is that after you pass this
encoded input through both your if you
pass this corrupted input through both
your encoder and decoder then the output
the eventual x-hat should be very close
to your original uncorrupted input yeah
so another
is a variational encoder which has a
cool comp probabilistic interpretation
so you can think of it as kind of a
Bayesian network I think maybe this is
more useful to look at so you have an
encoder and a decoder and they are both
modeling
I guess probability distributions so
what this is saying is I want to encode
X into a distribution over HS and you
learn a function which is in charge of
doing that and then you want to specify
some conditions first you say okay I
want to make X recoverable from my each
distribution and then second this is a
term that kind of it prevents h from
being degenerate so maybe a good way of
thinking about this is instead of so a
traditional auto encoder would take my
input and it would map it it would send
it through some kind of encoder and map
it into a hidden vector send that
through a decoder and that would
reconstruct my input whereas a
variational auto encoder is going to
take my input and it's going to map that
into a distribution over possible HS and
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to sample from this distribution pass
that through my decoder and produce my
reconstructed input and the nice thing
about this is that since this is a
distribution instead of a vector you've
imposed some structure on the space so
points that are close together in this
space should map to similar X hats and
then similarly as you move through this
space you should be able to gradually
transition from one I guess
reconstructed input to a second so for
example there's these cool experiments
and computer vision where they'll say up
here this is going to give me like a
chair or something and then down here is
going to give me like a table and then
if I move from one to the other then and
you constantly decode then it'll like
gradually morph into the table it's
really cool okay and then so then the
last method of unsupervised learning
that we're going to talk about is
motivated by this task so there's this
data set called squad which is about a
hundred thousand examples where each
example consists of a paragraph and then
a bunch of questions like multiple
choice questions based on that paragraph
so the problem here is that there's only
a hundred thousand examples and really
the intelligence that this task is
trying to get at is just can you read a
text and understand it which is more
general and this game is captured by
more data than just these hundred
thousand in particular it's captured by
just all the text that you could
possibly read so there's billions of
words on Wikipedia and Google you could
just crawl the web and download it and
if somehow you could leverage that maybe
that would be helpful for your reading
comprehension and that is just a perfect
case of this of this setting where we
have tons of unlabeled data
very small amount of labeled data so
recently the NLP community has come to
its idea called Bert well there's
actually not just Bert but there's a lot
of people who are doing similar things
but Bert is the example were talking
about with Bert what you do is you take
a sentence and then you mask out some of
the tokens in the input and then you
train a model to fill in those tokens
and they actually train the model on a
bunch of things so they trained on token
filling and then they also would glue
two sentences together and and ask the
model are these sentences like would
they be adjacent in the text or not like
do they make sense together or not but
the idea is basically like have give a
bunch of unlabeled text to a model which
is just going to kind of like manipulate
that data in order to learn structure
from it without any explicit purpose
other than just learning the structure
and they trained it on a bunch of data
for a long time and then what you can do
is once so Bert is actually a big so we
talked about transformers before and
birds like a big transformer so they
trained this thing on a ton of
unstructured text on just this word
filling task for a long time and then
what they did was they took their pre
trained Bert and they took the and they
started feeding it questions from squad
so they took questions and then they
would glue on to it the paragraph the
context that they used to answer the
question and then they would take
whatever vectors are coming out of Bert
and they would pass that through a
single matrix which basically predicts
the answer for that squad question and
it did really well so this picture is
right when Bert was released and these
are all of these state-of-the-art models
for squad and Bert not only beat all the
other models by a large margin
but also be human performance and I
guess the in the intuition the intuition
behind Burt was that by doing these
seemingly trivial tasks like word
filling and next sentence prediction
what you end up learning is you end up
learning the vectors are coming out of
this our vectors that say like what is
the meaning of a word what is the
meaning of a word in this context what
is the meaning of this sentence and that
meaning isn't like operationalized
towards solving any task in particular
it's just like a in a very general sense
like what is I'm gonna imbue this model
with an understanding of language and
then once I have an understanding
language I'm gonna then apply it to my
very targeted downstream task and that
is that is kind of the principle behind
unsupervised learning so you kind of
like make up these almost trivial
prediction tasks just to manipulate data
and learn structure from it understand
language understand what a picture is
and then what you do is then you
fine-tune it on the very small amount of
label data that you have and that's kind
of what the currents say the art is in a
lot of fields is basically just doing
more and more unsupervised pre training
with bigger bigger models and bigger
bigger data and the field really hasn't
found like a limit to this yet and it'll
be interesting to see how far it goes so
I'm gonna skip those slides but just to
kind of wrap things up recently I guess
the biggest things that people have
gotten to get neural hours working is
one better optimization algorithms so we
have these adaptive algorithms that are
not as I would say like obtuse as SGD
doesn't have to move in this by the same
amount every time you have a lot of
tricks like you know fine-tuning on
supervised learning clipping the
gradients batch norm we have better
hardware we have better data and that
allows us to experiment more and train
larger models faster yeah we wait a long
time but I think I think one of maybe
one of the problems with the field is
that the theory is is a lot of ways
lacking and we don't know exactly why
neural networks work well and why
they're able to learn good functions
despite having a very difficult like
optimization surface
yeah so just to summarize we we talked
about a lot of different building blocks
we talked about how to leverage spatial
structure with convolutional neural
networks we talked about how to feed
sequences into recurrent neural networks
and transformers and LSD m's we talked
about you know the sequence the sequence
paradigm for machine translation and
unsupervised learning methods that
helped you kind of like jumpstart your
downstream applications and I think the
big takeaway here is that and in some
ways the big advantage of a neural
network is that they are compositional
so you it's like a it's like Legos you
take they take an input and they turn it
into a vector and then once you have a
vector you can start combining these
things in very flexible ways and so in a
lot of ways designing these things is a
lot like putting together Lego set
you have your building blocks in LS TM
attention and coding and you can decide
how to it's like oh I want to run this
LS TM here and this else I'm here and
then I want this one to attend over this
one and then I'm going to concatenate
the result with the output of this CNN
and because of because of I guess you
could say like the magic about
propagation you can combine these things
and I think even more generally it
allows you as a programmer to instead of
make a program for solving a problem it
allows you to make this scaffolding that
allows a computer to teach itself how to
solve the problem so instead of defining
the function you want the software to
learn you define a very broad family of
functions that the software is allowed
to learn and then you let it go and run
off and find the best match within that
yeah so those are all
things talking about today but I hope
you all have a good Thanksgiving break